bloodborne is an action role-playing
game made by Japanese developer from
software brought to you by the same
creative team that made Demon Souls and
Dark Souls the story is set in a
Lovecraft meets Cronenberg meets Dickens
meets Bram Stoker dreamscape that is a
fantastic example of the cosmic horror
genre and that's why we're going to talk
about how the game's happiest ending is
actually its most depressing
it's become conventionals to talk about
games with multiple endings in terms of
the good ending versus the bad ending or
the good ending versus the evil ending
and so on and so forth because most
games with multiple endings do tend to
have a fairly unambiguous hierarchy
usually with the optimal ending being
more difficult with additional steps
required or just a generally superior
grasp of the game as hold needed jumping
through various hoops to save every
secondary character results in an ending
where almost everyone lives happily ever
after the end
blood-borne however inverts this typical
relationship providing three endings
that on a surface level are happier the
less effort you put into the game
story-wise the game doesn't branch much
through the bulk of its playtime
approaching things in a different order
or making key decisions will change the
fate of various individuals but the
overall plot remains ultimately fixed it
is intentionally obtuse bordering on
inscrutable something that is 100%
appropriate for the cosmic horror genre
even when the reader has the big picture
they are still left with an EIN
sensation that this big picture is but a
postage stamp-sized piece of a much much
bigger picture that they are not and
never will be privy to so the plot of
blood-borne starts long before the game
begins and it intentionally paints only
a vague sketch of events that happened
over the course of hundreds of years
ages and ages ago there was a
civilization called the Thumb Aryans who
had a connection with the old ones
otherworldly beings of immense power who
they worshipped as gods queen yharnam
their last ruler had a particularly
powerful connection to these beings but
things started to go bad so that the
Marion's retreated into their catacombs
and sealed themselves away over time a
town named yharnam after the Queen was
founded on the ruins and explorers
eventually found their way into the
catacombs where they discovered dark
secrets these dark secrets led to the
foundation of the Academy of Bergen
worth built studied things found in the
labyrinth and the rise of a cult called
the choir who in turn used that
knowledge to develop something called
blood ministrations had by doping blood
with various kinds of alien fluids
referred to as the old blood the choir
was able to perform healing miracles
give people superpowers tap into our
cane energies and a bunch of other stuff
one dude Willem the head of researcher
at Bergen worth figure this was probably
a bad plan but his protege Lawrence
decided to roll with it and founded the
Church has a way to distribute the blood
ministrations far and wide believing
that it would evolve mankind to a higher
level of being publicly the healing
church uses the ministrations to perform
miracles but privately the choir is
using them as a way to strengthen their
contact with the old ones under the
guidance of a being named Everett us
either way blood ministrations are a hit
and yharnam grows into a sprawling
Dickensian metropolis drawing people in
from near and far
however willem was right in the whole
process winds up turning random people
into monsters every cosmic event or so
the people of Jarno however with their
entire society revolving around the
healing church in these blood
administrations considers this to be an
acceptable side effect and a couple
dudes in the church's workshop ludwig in
gehrman came up with a simple solution
just to hunt down anyone who turns into
a werewolf and kill them thus the hunt
was born in the present you play as a
character who has come to yharnam to get
blood ministration to cure some
unspecified problem and in exchange for
the Cure you are roped into joining the
hunt over the course of the game you
discover that the hunt is basically a
covert way of maintaining the status quo
because every time a great one tries to
reproduce that's what triggers everyone
turning into monsters so the job of the
hunters is to kill monster people yes
but the main goal is to kill the new
baby old one in order to prolong
humanity's existence just a little bit
longer it's even more intricate than
that the lore notes scattered around the
world pepper and dozens of different
individuals and a handful of various
factions each with their own goals and
complex relationships to one another and
this is also where things start to go to
the weird side see like with a lot of
cosmic horror much of the logic of
blood-borne is founded on the idea that
people are simply incapable of seeing
things that are too alien that a giant
eldritch abomination could be hanging
out in the middle of town and even
though it would be right in front of you
you have no frame of reference to
comprehend it so your brain would simply
not know how to process it and would
just blank it out by extension the more
you know about the truth of the cosmos
the more you're able to see because you
now have a frame to put it in the
downside is that this shift in
perspective leads to madness or at the
very least a disconnection with the
ordinary in such a way that most would
interpret as madness with this in mind a
large portion of the hunt
place in this kind of altered state of
perception with the hunter seem fighting
and interacting with things that aren't
normally visible and that brings us to
the endings of the game after the player
survives the night and completes the
hunt they return to the hunter's dream a
pocket dimension that serves as the game
central hub and are told to go talk with
gehrman now gehrman's been sitting
around for the entire game as a kindly
old if slightly perverted mentor figure
you're welcome to use whatever you find
even the doll should be pleased but if
the player has been paying attention and
snooping around then they've pieced
together that the dude should have to be
pushing like 150 200 years by now he was
an original hunter so something's up
you go to talk to gehrman he
congratulate you on a job well done and
this is where the game splits into its
three endings the game offers you a
choice to submit or to resist if you
submit to gehrman he executes you in the
dream and you wake up the following
morning back in the real world to a new
sunrise on a new day if you resist then
you're forced to fight gehrman after his
defeat an entity approaches you picks
you up and you black out waking up in
gehrman's wheelchair as the new gehrman
the new keeper of the dream the new
director of the hunt however if you jump
through a bunch of Hoops throughout the
game collecting pieces of the old ones
and consuming them then you resist the
moon presence fight it and wake up as a
squid creature you have become an infant
old one yourself okay so if the three
endings are wake up as a squid wake up
as a slave and wake up to a new sunrise
how is the happiest ending actually the
worst ending well it's because of
knowledge and understanding the sunrise
ending is tragic because of what it
costs as gehrman tells you before your
execution you wake up having forgotten
everything about the hunt everything you
have learned about the old ones the
healing church the choir the truth about
yharnam and bergen work the fact that
humanity's most powerful institutions
are being steered by cosmic forces that
have their own unintelligible agendas
and conflicts that routinely wreak havoc
and destruction on
lady that the one institution that seems
to fight for the protection of humanity
the hunters is itself the construct of
some cosmic being that humanity is just
a pawn in an alien Civil War your hunter
gets to go on to live a long happy life
in a doomed world this is so
thematically poignant that this comes at
the end of a Souls born game
gameplay-wise the player has spent hours
and hours up to this point being taught
through experience how much it sucks to
get taken out by some unseen unstoppable
thing most of the players first
half-hour in the nightmare of mensis the
final major chunk of the game is going
to be spent yelling what's even killing
me as the player is bombarded by
insanity rays from this light house and
that's the tragedy of the happy ending
you're doomed
but you don't even know how dumb you are
in order to go back to a normal life all
that insight needs to be taken away or
else you would still see the things that
lurk around the corners of reality which
would ultimately drive you mad or to
something others would interpret as
madness the only way to be happy in the
world of blood-borne is to be ignorant
of reality conversely the best ending is
itself bittersweet with the hunter
gaining incomprehensible power being
evolved beyond the limitations of the
human form but at the cost of the last
remaining vestiges of their humanity as
with all souls born games there's an
element of futility in each ending a
cycle that the player is ultimately
incapable of breaking away from if the
player accepts gehrman's offer the cycle
of the hunt continues because the hunter
has forgotten everything about its true
nature
if the player rejects gehrman's offer
the hunter simply replaces him and the
hunt continues with the hunter compelled
to participate a slave to the cycle if
the player rejects the offering defeats
the moon presence then the hunter
transcends into a thing that has no
reason to care about humanity or the
fate of humans the exact outcome of this
scenario is more ambiguous than the
others but chances are it doesn't turn
out smashingly for the common folk of
the world and this is part of what makes
blood-borne such a good example of its
genre
it's a faithfulness to the kinds of
existential dread the sense of futility
that makes cosmic horror not just scary
but haunting because the longer you
think about it the more you accept that
you should indeed
fear the old blood